[Applause]
[Music]
okay good to get the green light thanks
to me and thanks for thanks to myself
for inviting myself today all right so
so the the top will really be on fully
homomorphic encryption from lattices I
have this what diamond pointed out is a
non committing title from this I could
be talking about one of several
different things but really I'll be
talking about fully homomorphic
encryption the rest of the day will be
so other kinds of things you can do for
novices so just get started
you know what so you know what our
lattices in lwe good for what I really
should be asking what our blood is and
lwe not good for and this light would
have been a little bit shorter I think
that they're good for as as you saw from
perhaps from Chris's talk it's to get us
to achieves to construct all kinds of
furs of old good old crypto you know
things that we knew how to do from other
assumptions you know factoring or
discrete logs or you know elliptic curve
discrete log or whatever we can server
create most of these things from the
hardness of Alta GUI that includes
public encryption which is already
oblivious transfer which you didn't see
but and you probably won't see today but
you can do it chosen ciphertext secure
encryption identity based encryption
which you did see hierarchical IB you
did not see it really this list keeps
going on and on the most recent kind of
kid on the block is a non interactive
zero knowledge proof for NP from the
hardness of LW you have very special
relationship with this problem because
four years ago it was at the Simons
program that I actually you know put a
bounty on this problem
and I lost so I'm not gonna make that
mistake again so this list keeps going
on and on really and lattices seemed
very lwe particular seems very versatile
and then you know we can also do crazy
crypto by which I mean just building to
the achieving notions that we did not
know that we still do not know how to
achieve from any other assumption fully
homomorphic encryption is perhaps the
the signature example of of one such
application the only way we know to
build fully homomorphic encryption of
any reasonable kind again this list
keeps going on and on fully on the
market signatures constrain to run of
functions which you will see at the end
of the day attribute based encryption
which straight I will tell you about
trying to tracing lock block this case
and I can keep going on and on you know
it's not that you should know all these
buzzwords but really you can do a ton of
things and at this point you know it
seems as if potentially you could do all
of cryptography it bakes all of
cryptography on the hotness of there yet
and that's intimately tied to the
question of building program obfuscation
or in distinguish there are still
frontiers to be explored for grand
unification of cryptography
very good so today it's crazy crypto day
and I'll begin with fully homomorphic
energy so what is fully homomorphic
encryption how many of you haven't seen
a definition of fully homomorphic
encryption here let's just calibrate
myself not have not that would be easier
I don't want everyone all of you to uh
you know alright so imagine to potty
okay there's an Alice who has an input X
and she wants to get it computed
complicated function on it she wants
someone else to do it the cloud but she
doesn't want to reveal X to the cloud so
what'd she do she encrypts X sends it to
the cloud and what you want the cloud to
do is to take the encryption of X and
somehow do magic there was something in
the encryption of f of X without
actually knowing what X and you know
once that's done you know the cloud
doesn't know anything they input the
intermediate sort of values in the
computation so it's the computation I'll
think about it is a function or really
concretely as a boolean circuit
arithmetic circuit doesn't know anything
doesn't know the result doesn't know the
import nothing once it's done the cloud
sensor dr. Alice who has the key she can
record it classical what do we need we
need correctness course that need this
commutative diagram that you know you
encrypt you homomorphic evaluate you
decrypt you should get the same result
that's actually computing the phifertex
or in general many ciphertext function
computes together and once you decrypt
you get it and security is uh what is
security security really you know most
commonly we think about security for
others okay that is whatever she sends
out of her system should hide her info
completely semantically or in an in CP a
sense rather the encryption of X or
rather a sequence of interruptions of X
should look like junk should look like
maybe encryptions of zero fuel so it's
the classical notion of CPA security no
change at all then there's a notion of
efficiency which is really what sir
formal market competition is about which
is it says that you know this phifertex
really should look like an encryption of
the result therefore banks you shouldn't
do complicated things like blow up the
size of the ciphertext proportional to
the computation time or the circuit size
this should look like you know the old
encryption of f of X way to formalize it
is that the length of the site the
texture the description length of the
ciphertext yeah the number of bits that
the cloud sends back to Alice should be
independent of the circuit size from
independent or logarithmic if you want
more for cloud why he feels left out
okay
so he says look you know I might want to
hide the function I'm computing from
Alice why not so Alice dust know
something about the function she learns
X come I've ever seen she lands one in
without repair yeah and I want to say
that that's it really you don't learn
anything else in other words that C
prime reveals no more than f of X to
Alice and Alice actually knows the
private key so she can actually decrypt
learn f of X clearly maybe more I want
to say no more that's it function
privacy in the literature
good so these are the two properties
yeah three properties for properties
correctness security compactness and
done I'm surprised and fully here means
that you know this interruption system
should be powerful enough to evaluate
any circuit any polynomial sighs all
right so let me start with two theorems
it makes our make our lives vastly
simpler vastly but simpler yeah the
first theorem says that function privacy
don't worry about it
so theorem of with Craig and Shai shows
that you can turn any homomorphic
encryption scheme generically without
any assumptions in the additional
assumptions into one which is also
function private so so really the card
thing is to is to hide the input and
compute on it hiding the function
depends what you mean by free monomial
if we are an asymptotic land here I'm
not going to the yesterday forget it
okay I I am I am going to assume that
both Alice and the cloud are on a
Spectre yes you can take care of it by
external means but not today thank you
but this is a theorem right it's a it's
a it's not a you know you can analyze
the polynomial blow up or whatever but
really it's as a theorem it says you
need to make no additional Sauron to
says you know you could define a secret
key version of homomorphic encryption or
a public key version yeah just like you
could define a secret key version of
interruption and a public key version
encryption beautiful theorem of rostrum
sayings that you can go from any secret
key for morphic encryption even
additively homomorphic encryption to
public key
we don't know how to go from a secret
heat encryption to a public key
encryption that would be major but if
you have a homomorphic secret key
encryption you can generically
completely generically Anna actually
quite efficiently convert it to public
key or marking encryption one could in
retrospect think of all the public key
homomorphic encryption schemes is doing
precisely with okay all right so these
theorems actually make our life simpler
because I don't care I want to care
about public key I don't want to care
about function privacy you know work
with the other additively homomorphic
private key encryption additively
homomorphic public intrusion so the
homomorphism whatever you had you more
or less preserve you lose a little bit
but you more or less preserve okay so
this is this is what that is the history
lesson I don't want to do too much of
feta I did spend quite a bit of time to
preparing the slides over yeah so the
notion was defined by back in the 70s
right after all say first of all mark
encryption scheme in some sense which is
CPA secure I think about it that's its
goal was to Maccabi oh it was the first
to CPA secure encryption scheme turned
out to be homomorphic as well so they
did multiplicate if you think about the
P Hellman the way we typically think
about it as a multiplicative Li
homomorphic encryption scheme over the
subgroup of quadratic residues people
lots of other additive or multiplicative
schemes over different groups and the
only kind of you know Sofer progress
that we made in was this work of a bond
ago anything where they showed how to do
I'll be totally many addition some
amorphic additions and one
multiplication let you figure it out
that's what
all right that's where we stood then
tons of more works which you could call
homomorphic encryption they don't look
like homomorphic encryption and call
them pretty the first breakthrough yeah
they don't look like a good roster
McCauley right the ciphertext is there
is a group element and then another
psychotics or another group element you
multiply group elements and then you get
another group but it's natural kind of a
more consumption but you could think
about more complicated things that have
the same properties which is compactness
and function privacy which don't look
like group elements could be something
more like garbled circuits for example I
came up with the first candidate fully
homomorphic encryption scheme for real
yeah that was a fantastic marked the
huge change for those of us who were
then actually too
and several people built on top of it
you know the the scheme was actually
based on a very strong set of
assumptions some of which are at least
one of which is known to be in quantum
polynomial time at this point according
to Leo right
but anyway so so Deltona set of
assumptions wasn't particularly
efficient but it was the first solution
landmark change from what existed and
then a couple years
Vica and i came up with the first lwe
based fhe scheme and that's what I'll
start telling you about built on top of
it with works maybe more and so you know
in the field we referred to this is the
first second third maybe the fourth
generation of fully homomorphic
encryption it's not clear what these
things actually among friends we so
Craig Gentry it's a high in water came
up with yet another lwe based FEC scheme
so you can say what is what's good about
it it's in fact actually less efficient
than then 2011 scheme so that what is
going on you keep seeing it throughout
the day it's essentially everything you
see today is built on top of do stuff
and that again was built on Leo and
Daniele had to work on its right to
building on it and ilaria is several
works at the top well generation well I
don't think this is my terminology I
consulted with any other experts is the
work of Jim he and others who came up
with an approximate
yes that's what is it better it solves
problems in practice that I wouldn't
solve it efficient it's more efficient
it's a nicer in a different sense than
GSW you know what I mean
actually you don't know what I mean but
but that doesn't matter but that's
matter it's a different scheme you look
at you know it's sort of like look at
this you know I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go for BB I realize that I had the last
time I gave a talk about BB was in San
Diego so Daniel it's not correct that I
didn't get ever give a talk about it
they talk about it in San Diego in 2011
train that so 10 years pass hopefully I
remember all the schemas just W if I get
to it and finally I want to say you know
so here's the thing of history right so
you know these schemes that old-world
schemes most of it is obsolete you know
but there are very nice ideas that
persist from these works Craig's work
came up with the idea of bootstrapping
homomorphic encryption scheme until you
get to it and that really is only way we
know to get a real fully homomorphic
encryption scheme one that can evaluate
arbitrary circuits without any stars
very very nice side yet persists to this
day major open question whether you can
actually get rid of that one
it's a persisting contribution from the
original then again you know a smart and
burkhardt run came up with this idea of
so [ __ ] many cipher texts into one
impacting many plaintext into one
ciphertext and computing on it together
what is now called the sim D mode of
evaluation which is again fantastic it
is persisted to this day and people have
built on it and really the reason why
Fitch is even
thought of as being remotely practical
at this point owes a lot to these works
have their value and yes yes yes
actually Nigel and Frey took Craig
scheme simplified it and they also
showed how to actually do then syrup we
built on it in BG b and then centrical
Aviance Martin from so on it's for them
it's originated from there as far as I'm
so that's what we're gonna do yeah so
one two and three and you probably only
get to one but up so let's start with
the Big Bang which is reggae in fact
even before I gave there is proto rocket
there which is the following scheme to
encrypt the message m with what is that
second parameter is the noise rate it
sort of measures how big or small the
noise is here's what I do and you've
seen this already you pick a random
vector a the Q to the N you think about
it as an integer rector Z to the N you
add a noise which is bounded add the
message to it I think of the message as
an element in Z mod Q Z at this point
but it is not here so I take the liberty
tor hidden watch it later
looks like I can talk to him he can talk
back to me so distinct advantage all
right so so here's the syntactic change
I don't want to think about through a
comma B in the ciphertext really you
want to think about the ciphertext is
one vector and one dimension higher such
that the inner product of this vector
with the secret key which is again the
old secret key concatenated with one or
minus one is infact the ever plus
message I didn't do anything it's just a
syntactic change makes my life easier
all right if I can encrypt number a
second into practice just encrypt them
separately the ciphertext would be a
matrix instead of a vector whose product
with the secret key is an error vector
plus the message nothing
all right so good thing about it is all
these things that I showed before are
additively homomorphic you take two
ciphertext add them together you know it
is an encryption of many messages whew
well you would have noticed already that
when I add to size of X the error
increases this is a curse that's going
to be with us for life for the life of
this talk and for the life of Gladys
with photography but gross to double
what it was before it's not a big field
who can handle it all right what what I
would like is I would like to what is
next after addition scalar
multiplication potential right I'd like
to take a ciphertext the interruption of
M and I'd like like to compute an
encryption of some scalar alpha times
the mass and that doesn't work at least
yeah right wait doesn't why obvious
thing I would do is I would take the
ciphertext multiply it with the scalar
what I would do is it would multiply the
message with the scale I wrote so
multiply the noise with the scalar
really I want to think about the scalar
is an arbitrary number and Z mod Q Z so
it increases the noise by a great deal
noise could really be an arbitrary
number or vector in Z Marcos
that's all good yeah okay so we wanna
show you here the first variant of total
I get Bailey this is what I get for me
here when I want to encrypt the message
m
I don't sort of encrypt M rather I
encrypt and conserve with G which is a
fancy way of saying look at the big
vector whose coordinates whose
concatenation of M - M 4 M all powers of
2 times the message resource it's a
vector that is roughly log Q factored
longer than M itself encrypt that that's
that's what I'm greater now I claim that
suddenly this actually supports scalar
multiplication so the one thing to
notice is that even the old thing if I
multiplied it for the scalars are used
where small but is 0 or 1 it's good
because the noise grows by I don't know
zero or x one which is great right so
that's good
it was somewhat scalar multiplier but
this one is fully scalar multiplier Bo
and how do you do it it's the oldest
trick in computer science think of bits
okay yeah in other words take the
ciphertext take the plaintext sorry
alpha break it up into bits now you have
an encryption of yeah so I what I want
to compute this alpha times m of course
I can write this this and so C to D is a
beautiful thing bits you have
encryptions of 2 to the I times n you do
scalar multiplication except with small
constants yes this is such a know we
will actually I think we did it for the
first time in BB but I'm so embarrassed
- we were so embarrassed to say ovp
invented bit decomposition it doesn't
make any sense but you know it it's a
it's it gives us such huge mileage you
can trace its origin in lattice
cryptography to a work of I type 99 very
came up at flood doors this is you know
they can trace its origin in humanity to
uh to the notion of this take it back to
the knapsack cryptosystem and the super
increasing sequences is that right yeah
yeah you see you can never go back
directly so very simple trick
lets you do scalar multiplications by
arbitrary scalars and this will keep
showing up this sort of notion of the
decomposition alright so now you can
actually do scalar multiplication the
noise increases from EDA which is what
it was there before no to either x lock
you why lock you because you're adding
up log too many psychotics a number of
bits in a number is lock you bits you're
adding up any of the those many things I
can do scalar multiplications I can do
inner products as well all right it's
just a scalar multiplications and
additions
yeah so this I can do as well very good
so amorphic addition a morphic scalar
multiplication you're making two-thirds
of the way through yeah
yes yes yes
so this is what it is yeah so so that
m10 Shoji I think about it is a vector
with M 2 m 4m all right so all that's
left is some of our big multiplication
yeah
well that's really the heavyweight thing
to do that let's actually go back to
what let's forget the proto and let's
relieve for a dead of the picture and
let's go back to what we know is that I
give to encryption which is e thermos
yeah you could really think so what is
the problem with the with with proto II
of the message you know it wasn't the
message could be completely recovered
what you could recover is the message
plus the error which is not the entire
message yeah so so this is you should
think of it as an error corrected
version of structure again in fact
actually what we built proto regev prime
is also an error corrected version so
what I do is instead of putting an M
here I put an error corrected version of
n which is n times Q now when you
decrypt what you recover is e plus n Q
over to and and you can read out the
most significant
okay so Norfolk edition is great
decryption is great right I'm going to
burden you with one more sort of variant
to forget all this is building towards
the grand finale of homomorphic
multiplication trust me yeah this is you
know another thing that we notice it's
after Leah elementary observation that
in al weq doesn't matter what is the
ratio of the noise to the modulus hue is
sort of extraneous one way to kind of
formulate it is by saying look you know
I can think about the lwe ciphertext C
as living not with result reference to
any particular modulus but over the
torus divide the whole ciphertext by Q
what you get is the ciphertext that
lives in the torus times the secret key
which is an integer vector which is
Error error also get slashed by Q and
what you get this
and really these two schemes are you can
go but these two settings you can go
back and forth you know it's multiplied
or divided by Q one thing I do want to
point out is that this type attack
doesn't live completely in the torus
arbitrarily in the torus
it's actually multiples of 1 over Q this
will come out later but yeah so we came
up with like four schemes just to wrap
yeah
summarize proto racket which didn't even
have decryption correctness we modified
it in two ways one is to allow for
scalar multiplication addition always is
the case always true it also got scalar
multiplication we call that PE prime
photolocket prime we modified it to get
the classical drag F yeah which has
homomorphic addition correctness and
scalar multiplication yes of course
because the scheme encrypts bits so then
the final variant is is just a modulus
reduced version of that ok now it's time
to put them together to get more so
so let's this is Vika so let's let's do
it
so I take two cipher texts and
encryption encryption of M Prime and
really one of these encryptions I'm
going to think about it as the flag of
encryption and the other one I'm gonna
think about it is a modulus reduced or
scale invariant for a given function as
we saw we can go back and forth so no
problem all right
yeah [ __ ] you and this is mod 1
all right so let's you know we are
actually working with two different
groups so it's not to get confused with
ourselves so myself for that matter I'm
going to explicitly write it as sum the
Marcuse plus Q times some integer this
is plus some integer and now the cipher
to everything is over integers or
rational
all right so what do I want to do I want
to drum C and C prime construct a cipher
text which decrypts in the sense of
inner product with the secret key to an
arrow plus the product of the messages
times Q over two so in other words I
want to come up with their I gave
encryption of the product of the two
messages make sense this is the goal is
what I want all right how should we do
it and really this was the bottleneck
for at least for us for a long time for
a few months
yeah we thought of homo mark how would
you do homomorphic encryption okay you
want to add and multiply second yes so
it makes sense to work with an
underlying object which supports both
additions and multiplications in other
words called the ring yeah so without
rings how can you possibly do encryption
that was a bottleneck that we were
hitting against hitting against hitting
against hitting against one morning you
realized that you can clean a little out
of the box and you can actually multiply
vectors vectors in a vector space
it's not one morning and then we tried a
few different things yeah so you can you
can do it and for those of you who
haven't seen it
who's that oh okay all right
wait very good okay so then you should
have written the paper you know we tried
like five different things like that
dude it'll be yeah so so you can't
answer the two psychotics yeah
multiplying by two is sister noise you
can't answer the two separate X and what
happens you just take the two left-hand
sides of this equation and multiply them
together sir numbers right you multiply
them together best times C prime in a
product s is see tensor C prime in a
product s tensor is right so what I'm
really doing is multiplying the two
left-hand sides I'm not good what do I
get
don't do I can said well I multiply the
two right-hand sides yes and brace for
it some ugliness that comes into picture
and you you trust me or you can go back
and verify can you know the color video
this is really a small arrow why because
this just to stop it this is an error
that's is a small error relative to Q
and E prime is the number that's smaller
than one so it can only reduce the size
of the error further small mark you and
prime plus two Z Prime
well number what I want it to be a small
number if it is a small number of you
you never of size boolean independent of
cube and here is the key signal all
right well hold that thought for a
second yeah so and then you get Q times
a multiple which I don't care about the
small amount of a lot I don't care about
it so really this guy is good mark you
really it's Leo's question what is how
large is the arrow good
so the error length is proportional to
the actual arrow like E which is like
8r8 cube railing - smaller than I think
of it is smaller than cube this is also
a 2 cube because I had an error in the
tourists multiplied by Q it is smaller
but really the question is how large are
Z and Z multiplied with the secret key
these are vectors in Z Q to the N
potentially write the coefficients is
largest Q multiply them how large can
they get Q squared could be as large is
Q
I'm dead right here's a beautiful
theorem of bomb cash buy curtains ah hi
who show that l-dub you Eve it's small
secrets with a small mean you choose the
secret from the arrow distribution as
well as the arrow yes they're small and
the view is exactly as hard with small
secrets as with the random sequence so
if they are somewhat stupid to begin
with to use random secrets and so much
entropy that that entropy didn't matter
at all I mean here all these you should
really have used small secrets yeah
that's beautiful
because then what it tells us is that
this Z the length is proportional to L 1
norm of s therefore the noise close by L
1 norm fest which is small Pollyanna
so you know the pieces were there at
this point we think of the ACPs theorem
as I give it as an exercise in my in my
class but at that point we were like
yeah so so this is this is that then you
need to round it because this doesn't
live in gmod QZ it has so rational
coefficients with you around it it
doesn't matter the rounding error again
introduces an error proportional to the
l1 norm of AX spence arise again is
small because that's what you get out of
this
it's a ciphertext whose inner product
with s if you squint okay but yeah
something like S Plus is looks exactly
like a ragged ciphertex in fact this is
a racket ciphertext a relative to the
private key a Spencer I not relative to
F itself which is what we wanted now if
you do it again it'll be a volunteer to
a stencil s10 so rest and so a suburban
then you you you die for modulus
reduction which is what we did you do
need us to be small yeah
very annoying I know that's because is
is very bothered by it doesn't matter in
practice depending on where you do
things at the same time or you do this
is key switching operation would you
change about the modulus yes yes if you
do only one of the two and then
depending what company showed you do you
can do slightly different things one of
these things does not require the key to
be smaller
I forgot I I well you know again as I
said in 10 years and I forgot i
reconstructed the whole thing from
scratch so I could have been but okay
a beautiful question up line see the
result already in one of my papers it
turns out or not you know brickowski 12
I do think needs needs us to be small
I'm fairly sure unless brickowski can
communicate back wait why do you care so
much
that's that's my question that's my
question too I agree with both of you
let me do my talk sorry
beautiful question
we bought one scheme because a you can
you can that's that's a that's a that's
a that's a if you just use to mark you
schemes ever blows up a lot and if you
use to mod one schemes that's fine
except later in a minute I'll see I'll
want this ciphertext to actually be
integer yeah completely equivalent
completely equivalent totally cool yeah
so you know again i said you know i
reconstructed this from scratch
following actually you know the in
plugged analyst talk from your crypto
against will reconstruct the GSW scheme
from scratch very nice and i said for
you know should be able to do that for
for BBS but right now all right so so
not happy with this because now the
encryption scheme is an either I give
encryption scheme is a regular
interruption of the product of the bits
but under a much larger kid therefore
the size of Texas alone I want to reduce
the size of the ciphertext so what we
called that dimension reduction in the
BB paper but really this is a technique
that you could use to switch an
encryption of a message under any they
could be the same side one could
actually you could be switching to a
larger key for what reason I don't know
but but let's you can using this
technique so so Craig sort of crushingly
call it key switching
alright so again what do I want to do
this is what I want to do I want to come
up with the cipher text which decrypted
with us is the encryption of M M times
the same message under a shorter so they
want to do
now comes fantastic for another
fantastic property of her that I give
encryption scheme which is linearity
encryption if you look at it is a linear
function of the secret key so whatever
is here yeah I mean you have a linear
function whose coefficients depend on
the site that actually apply that linear
function to the secret key what you get
is a message not quiet but you get and
then you need to do some sort of a
thresholding or rounding but more or
less it's a linear just beautiful that's
amazing and that's really what I would
be a good negotiator so what we gonna do
is we're going to sort of change things
a little bit where you're going to have
a public evaluation key so what is V I
have the secret key I'm Alice I have the
secret here I'm encrypting stuff to be
computed on I am also going to publish
an evaluation key which will help the
cloud do this key switching operation so
poor thing it cannot do it by itself I'm
going to actually help it out of course
they don't want help it up too much
all right so decryption so so what is
decryption again it's an inner product
what is an inner product its scalar
multiplication with large coefficients
potentially because C has large
coefficients mod Q and addition so we do
know a scheme which supports yeah scalar
multiplications and additions which is
what we called proto reggae back in the
days back in the hours so the evaluation
key is a proto raghav encryption of is
an oosik that is all secret and so the
one that we are going to switch from
under the key that we are going to
switch to I'm going to publish this
let's see if this actually helps what
this key does is it allows you to apply
the linear function which is C in a
product s times s right the linear
function take an encryption of s times s
and I multiplied with C in volatility
and P in a Protestant arises arrow + + Q
/ - yeah which really is the encryption
of that I give encryption of the message
so okay so you say okay you know what
I'm going to alice is going to publish
this encryption of as tensor that's with
this okay then you ask is that actually
an okay thing to do
we're depending on who you ask so this
problem that you know publishing an
encryption of s tensor s undress is okay
it's called circular the circular
security problem so we don't know that
status maybe it's okay maybe it's not
you can assume that it's okay and things
work so so in reality if you don't want
to make these sort of funny assumption
you want to do everything from lwe and
i'll the view ii only you can't do this
what you do instead is you switch from s
tensor app to a new secret key s prime
so rather you encrypt s 10 surahs with a
new secret key s Prime
that's okay these two what you're
encrypting and what you're encrypting
under are independent so that's actually
okay semantic security CPA security
guarantees if this is fine and I say
okay fine so that that's what you go
from an interruption under s to an
encryption address Prime now I want to
do another multiplications what do I go
under you know s double prime you know
and to do that I need to publish an
interruption of s prime tensor s Prime
and s double prime so you need to really
produce a chain of these
well then if I published hundred length
chain I can evaluate depth hundreds from
America in that hundred circuits public
ear per Acutes will be sufficient
private key is sufficient under SS res
right because it's not the same like in
order to perform it so a you can
actually compute you as and you don't
know the secret key yeah you can
actually compute an encryption of a
message under the secret key the message
itself is the link is an encryption of
the message under the secret key yeah so
the secure encryption but you don't care
about security I'm doing so zero comma M
Q over 2 is an encryption of the message
that I give encryption message on the
all right so good so this is it so so
this is the big picture what does the
interaction scene consists of a consists
of an evaluation key which is a sequence
of private keys Ted in this way yeah
each time you evaluate a multiplication
you first do to answering you go to
start from encryption under s to s 10
surahs then you use one level of the
evaluation key to go to s prime then you
multiply its prime tensor s prime then
you go to s double Prime
so yeah I did and use multiplication
again [ __ ]
sorry second yeah yes no it's it's in a
product at the end of the day so it does
you do at the end of this two-step
process get an encryption that looks
exactly like before in the sense if you
start with an n-dimensional ciphertext
we'd get an N dimensional center then
you tensor grow and then you shrink the
thing is you can only keep going for you
know a pre-specified number of levels in
it so this is called that it is all we
could get without circular security so
we call it a level homomorphic
encryption
okay the scheme says it has a ton of
nice property first it's a very easy
thing to adapt whatever I did to the
ring setting to the ring of the Beuys
city completely trivial an exercise in a
undergraduate class I would say go that
far and now in fact you can also do
modular interviewing this is what we did
in b2b we called this generalized aldub
Yui in BGP oh it's really what's called
modular and once you go to the ring
setting you can actually do sort of sim
D computations in other words you can
you don't need to encrypt one bit which
is what we did can you clip the sequence
of bits or the sequence of numbers then
you can sort of adds vector of numbers
and you can coordinate wise add and
multiply these things just in one shot
okay just fantastic trick one shot you
get an operation lower than that you can
actually compute unpacked ciphertext it
doesn't is resume how does simply a
computation house if you want to compute
the same function on many in on server
in parallel on many sites many inputs
that's where Cindy helps yeah you do the
same operation on there what if you just
have one input per person you know I
just have a Bigfoot they want to compute
on it but I don't want to sort of look
at Sophie I don't want to encrypt each
number separately I want to encrypt all
of them together they want to compute
inside the ciphertext
fantastic sort of property of the scheme
not all in the original works lots of
works kind of actually built
this is Jack tariqa libyan dream i think
if you think of it as a module right 10
select bring up the view is like a you
know two-dimensional one solution it
works exactly the same way
no no no but that's the thing bring up
the view is not a it's not a even if you
work with rangel to be Westman scheme
you still need tense right because it's
it no no no no polynomial ax w earring
out to be everything you need tense why
because the ciphertex are always two
dimensional vectors over the ring if you
use ring on the viewing then if you
which is within the sensor you go from
you know yeah i mean this it's another
way of looking at it if you have a
fundamentally different way of looking
at it yeah go for it i mean i be very
happy to get rid of the tense right no
please arrange yeah right so here we are
transferring over Z and there you would
answer over the you know
unless you're working with Andrew where
things are different I mean Andrew is
really the ring skin you know bring out
the view is not a ringing scheme it's a
module ski all right so we can take a
plane now it's time to I have seven
minutes
really all right okay it's not a
one-hour break
you should read your e-mails know what I
mean I mean is the following let's get
to it in five minutes
yes yes I do
oh you're the session chair okay okay so
so you know what you can now I'm not
going to tell you about the GSW scheme
super nice and the thing is you go to
youtube you have five different talks on
just of you so I'm not gonna really add
much to it very nice I came back to
really it's two slides okay yeah
compared to uh I don't know ten slides
so it's much more compactly described
very nice
let's compare quickly right so so it
turns out that bgv and vivian brickowski
and so far they we admit shorter
ciphertex in other words you encrypt a
message into a vector in the in the
primitive version of the scheme or if
you use the ring lwe encrypt a vector
into a vector yeah so the packing
constant is you know the plain text to
ciphertext ratio is some constant
east of you doesn't why haven't told you
what just of us but uh but it encrypts a
vector into a matrix what it actually
does worse you can solve these sort of
short ciphertext problems are
syntactically with hybrid encryption so
you never encrypt the message you
encrypt it Prime you know AES key and
then you yeah but but it doesn't in real
life Oh am i I might order that new good
decidedly younger than me says yes so so
just a few it has okay so that's one
sort of disadvantage if you could call
it off just W and the reason why I
disturb you is not like used all over
the place just playing that's it you
know you'll still use the BGP
yeah but geez W has tons of other nice
properties ten sorry that's low a nice
growth doesn't matter what what it is
but really the important property of
just of you is that it's a very
expressive scheme you can start from
gist of you and do not just fully
homomorphic encryption but fully
homomorphic signatures attribute based
encryption predicate encryption
everything that you're going to see
today later is essentially
very very nice game so really it is
still open how to come up with the best
of both worlds game people have sort of
done that in some senses but I do my
best of my knowledge there is no
satisfactory fully satisfactory solution
just W that encrypts a vector into
vector never makes it into a matrix
close to a lock do you factor way yeah
instead of a log Q vector length vector
that's what you would get from deviating
it's a lock you buy lock you matrix it's
still away
still still a factor of lock your way
it's not n lock you away but matrix into
a vector no no no you can't no no no
it's just taking one row of it yeah yeah
inside the computation you still have
inside the computation that's automatic
but then you can compress it to vector
then you make animated vector yes one
has to be a metrics in the other has to
be a victor to make the product possibly
yeah okay yes exactly right exactly
exactly that's that's the problem this
is the open problem yeah so really like
do bv accept nicely
okay
so so it turns out so all we did was
sort of homomorphic encryption leveled
homomorphic interruption beautiful just
gonna state it the proof is two slides
long but I don't have to slice time what
you can do this is from Craig's original
work in the beautiful theorem they said
if you have a morphic encryption that
can roll it let me put it this way if
you have decryption algorithm is simple
it can be evaluated in a small
multiplicative that it's a D and your
homomorphic encryption is just powerful
enough to evaluate the decryption
circuit B plus one that if you want then
you get fully really fully homomorphic
encryption meaning I can publish fix the
parameters of the scheme encrypt a
message using these parameters and you
can later decide you want to compute a
million depth circuit theory you can do
it fantastic one more thing about the
they're going from leveled to fully you
actually need we worked hard to sort of
say you know you don't need LW you need
want to do everything from al the
viewing but the only way we know to get
fully homomorphic encryption is making
the circular security assumption which
roughly says publishing an encryption of
the secret key under the secret key
is it okay I'll the beauty that's really
what I would like to prove but we don't
know okay so I nice like alright so so
the open problem is either prove that
bebe or GSW one of these schemes is in
fact circular secure you can actually
encrypt the secret key under the secret
key and it's it's okay secure and read
the view E and really turns out you
don't have to think about two different
problems turns out they are the same
problem the circular security assumption
you need for both teams is the same it's
not surprising to me but completely
eliminate this whole bootstrapping
method or just find a completely
different way to directly do fhe it's
high level ID or is it provable
disprovable yeah this is just writing it
down
you know yes yes
just write it down
we can write it down a flight okay so
yeah it's not surprising actually many
other things you can do we can do multi
key fhe can computer on encryptions
under different keys
whatever that mean lots of
implementations is not even complete
things here which you can't see
standardization all right so let me
leave you with three questions one yeah
like with two of them I already told you
about
best of all schemes you know me and just
w-why circular security I really don't
know I'm very conflicted about this on
the one hand you know there are sort of
recent results then go ahead Rishabh
where it's very sharp Grail cupola and
what is Bank Adama theater and what is
they showed an example of an encryption
scheme which is secure CPA secure but
not so close secure somewhat contrived
scheme but it's actually another view
based scheme so I think why is it not
rugged okay so I'm now I'm starting to
get a little antsy I'm a little and
before I think of course I give this
surplus security so if we nice to prove
that lwe Regev is so classic you it
turns out that there's a completely
different way to get pure fhe from this
thing called indistinguishability
obfuscation which refers to which does
not refer to there is a way to bypass
circular security except you replace it
with the huge hammer okay
now that gives me finally you know is a
philosophical question okay the only way
we know to do eleven fhe or f80 is with
lattices somewhat antithetical to the
point of this whole program let me ask
do we
there are proposals there is a very nice
framework of cugino EDA and Craig gave
talks about it but I don't think it's
ever been written down using sort of non
commutative group actions to to get
fully homomorphic interruption the
framework has never been instantiated
securely as far as I know it's very nice
you know if you really want to do
something you want to come to the latest
program and eliminates the need for
lattices you know maybe that's a that's
a yeah so that's IO implies circular
secure encryption generically I don't
think seems possible you can do it but
there's an exact I don't think there's a
paper that I turned on this good
question then then you're a my argument
would be if I Oh actually implies IO
actually implies the existence of an
encryption by the correct me if I'm
wrong which is secure but not circular
secure the other way round but maybe IO
implies the classical I'm not sure
okay all right so this is really all I
want to say both danila and I maintain
sort of page with tons of links for
later to sort of work on fhe and updated
when we are have nothing better to do I
update it and I have nothing better to
do very often so that's that take
questions
[Applause]
yeah yeah that actually means that
actually implies what I said right you
can switch from q2 so you square the
size of cube and you get n over 2
exactly so that means if I take the same
dimension
and plus increase Q keep fr the same
lives in a world where n bits and twin
bits of security also same yeah I I
think that's that's maybe because this
is this going from one modulus to
another modulus it does add error add
arrow to this scheme which is polynomial
in the cigarettes also you know is the
same but it means for the same dimension
a larger Q gives you what you can't do
it you can go from a larger modulus to a
smaller modulus with modulus reduction
it doesn't go the opposite way
in fact Chris does go the yeah the B
LPRs does go the opposite way which yeah
you also matters
cycie is using enloc you yeah absolutely
one direction maybe it would still like
to convince you that I'm right litter
going down you can go from n dimension q
modulus to n dimension Q Prime smaller
than Q modulus without any loss small
level
we can actually do it from I think Nigel
and friends had a work that showed how
to do it from the lightest knowledge of
an exponent better risk we have a work
with Ron and Silas and
so it's completely it's so there are new
ones as to what I'm saying maybe it's
worth mentioning this is not cotton
people here I think the knowledge
assumption that this meant is that paper
is no idea what it is to begin with so
it's basically the assumption that if
you can produce a BDD instance you know
the answer of its and quantum is it's
not sure
oh I see you're saying just prepare a
superposition measure of the that's it
you're not doing anything fancy
all right so so then now let me get to
diamonds I want to meet with the lattice
program participants to decide on what
you're doing for the semester we would
like to kind of do some joint activities
one of the things is one of the things
is a seminar on lattices which Noah and
Krishna are already organizing and
they'll be in touch with on future good
ideas for talks but we also want to do
potentially other things I've talked to
some a few personally through one-on-one
and you have suggested ideas but I want
after selectively the pin Buddhists what
if any anything would like to do
together collaboratively in a special
way so we'll meet one one six which is
you know right next to Martinez office
now for half an hour
feel free to sort of take five minutes
to get coffee